OF THE ASSEMBLY OF BUDGET SUB
FIVE COMMITTEES NOW CALLED ORDER.
COULD YOU PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
WEBER.
HERE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONER.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WE CAN
BEGIN IN THOSE WHO ARE LATE WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE.
AT THE END ON THOSE ITEMS WHEN
THEY COME IN. OF AS SOME OF YOU
FIRST OWNER THANK THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
AND HAVE BEEN WITH US FOR THE
LAST ROOM AND ON HOW MANY MONTHS
NOW BUT.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
WITH SUB FIVE WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU ALL
OVER THAT PERIOD OF TIME WHERE
WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR.
YOUR CONCERNS REGARDING THE
VARIOUS ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
PUT FORTH TO US AS WELL AS THAT
MEET WITH SOME OF YOU PERSONALLY
IN AND MY OFFICE OR THE
CONSULTANT'S OFFICE. TO CLARIFY
ADDITIONAL ISSUES.
BUDGET IS ALWAYS A DIFFICULT
TIME BECAUSE IT IT BASICALLY
SIGNALS THIS IS WHAT OUR VALUES
ARE GOING TO BE IN THE COMING
YEAR. IN TERMS OF HOW WE'RE
GOING TO UTILIZE OUR RESOURCES.
WE HOPE WE'VE HEARD EVERYONE.
AND.
AND THAT.
LEAD YOU ARE CLEAR ABOUT THE OF
THE THINGS THAT TO HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT FORWARD. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE TODAY IS REALLY A VOTE ONLY
MEETING. AS SO THEY'LL BE NO
PUBLIC COMMENTS PANELS OF
DISCUSSIONS IS THAT THINGS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED.
AND.
AND SO THIS IS AN AGENDA WITH I
THINK THEY'RE FORTY SEVEN ITEMS.
AND.%
IT'LL BE A VOTE ONLY AGENDA
THAT'S WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO
WAIT FOR SOME OF THE MEMBERS TO
COME.
TO BE A PART OF IT THEY WILL
GET A CHANCE TO VOTE HOPEFULLY
ONCE THEY ARRIVE. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE DON'T WANT TO DELAY
THE MEMBERS WHO OR WHAT DILIGENT
AND FAITHFUL ENOUGH TO GET HERE
ON TIME. A WAITING FOR THOSE WHO
ARE YOU KNOW MAYBE CHILLIN OUT
ITS STARBUCKS IS SOMEWHERE I
HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT IN ANY EVENT.
ALLOW THEM TO VOTE NEAR THE AND.
THIS BRINGS US TO THE FORTY
SEVEN ITEMS THAT WE'RE VOTING ON
AS A SUB OF FIVE COMMITTEE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
ARE WE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE.
AND THIS ISSUE CONCERNING
STANDARDIZED STAFFING AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO APPROVE AS
BUDGET. BROKAW WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY THREE OH VOTE
AND WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
MEMBERS WHO ABSENT.
I ISSUE TOO IS A JANITORIAL
SERVICES AND THIS IS TO REJECT
THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT TRAILER
BILL. UP PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE OF ROLL CALL WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
MELENDEZ SIGN PRINCETON YES.
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY THREE OH AND WE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS.
THE CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ACADEMY THIS IS ADOPT PLACE
HOLDER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT ON A THREE OH
VOTING WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
OTHER MEMBERS. ISSUE FOR THE
VEHICLE PURCHASING AUTHORITY OF
THE PRISON AND INDUSTRY
AUTHORITY OFF THE AUTHORITY OF
WE ADOPTING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AT THIS ROLL CALL.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER LACKEY
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS ALSO APPROVED ON A THREE
OH VOTE WILL HOLD IT OPEN.
FACILITY MANAGEMENT AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSAL WE ARE ADOPTING
THE PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BROKE OFF WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ
STAYING.
STONE.
IF THAT IS A TWO ONE ABSTENTION
AND IT'LL BE HELD OPEN OF FOR
THE OTHER VOTERS SO THAT IS ON
CALL.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
A A. B. NINE HUNDRED LEASE
REVENUE APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY
ADOPT THE PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
OKAY THAT IS APPROVED ON A THREE
OH VOTE.
.
AND WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
THOSE MEMBERS WHO ABSENT.
.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS THE
PELICAN BAY STATE PRISON
FACILITY DR. RECOMMENDATION IS
APPROVED AS BUDGET IT ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ NO STONE.
THERE IS A OUT ON A THREE ONE
VOTE AND THAT WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA EARLY EARTHQUAKE
WARNING SYSTEM THIS IS TO
APPROVE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
TOOL UP APPROVED THE PROPOSAL
WITH PLACE HOLDER. TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO SUBMIT A
PLAN.
OF ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FOUR ZERO
VOTING WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE. OF NINE ONE
ONE SUSTAINABILITY THIS IS TO
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL ENDED UP
TRAILER BILL.
LANGUAGE O. ROLL CALL WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY MELENDEZ
AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A THREE OH VOTER
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
A ISSUE NUMBER TEN WHICH IS
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS A COW THIS IS TO
APPROVE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
TO ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL. WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ
AYE STONE.
IF THAT IS OUT ONLY THREE OH
VOTE AND WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
I'M SORRY IT'S FOUR ZERO VOTE.
A ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN OF THIS IS
A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT SERVICES VISITS TO
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL. BROKAW
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FOUR OH VOTING
WILL HOLD IT OPEN. ISSUE TWELVE
SERVICES FOR VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING APPROVED THE
PROPOSAL.
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FOR ALL VOTING
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ISSUE THIRTEEN WHICH IS
THE INTERNET CRIME PUTS AGAINST
CHILDREN.
WITH THIS IS A VOTE TO APPROVE
THE PROPOSAL.
ROCCA WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
IS THAT IS OUT ONLY FOR ALL VOTE
AND WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THIS IS
CONCERNING THE FAMILIES JUSTICE
CENTERS APPROVED THE PROPOSAL.
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS NOT ONLY FOUR OH VOTE
AND HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ISSUE FIFTEEN THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER.
APPROVED THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT
BUDGET LET BILL LANGUAGE.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER LACKEY
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
OKAY THOSE OUT MONEY FOR ALL
VOTE WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE.
OF AN ADD ON FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ISSUE SIXTEEN THE CITY
OF RESULT OF THIS IS TO PROVE
THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL. WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ
AYE STONE.
IF THAT IS OUT ONLY FOR ALL
VOTING WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO VOTE. ISSUE
SEVENTEEN THE CYBERSECURITY
INVESTIGATION TEAM THIS IS ADOPT
THE LA OR RECOMMENDATION AND
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ROLL CALL. WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE.
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FOUR OH VOTING
WILL HOLD OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ISSUE EIGHTEEN THE ARMED
AND PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM. OF
THIS IS TO PROVE THE PROPOSAL
AND ADOPT BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
ROCKWELL WEBER ARE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON THE FLOOR
OVERLOAD AND WE WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
STATE OFFICER ISSUED NINETEEN
THE STATE OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING INVESTIGATION TEAMS IS
APPROVAL POLL THEM ADOPT BUT
PLACEHOLDERS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ROLL CALL. WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER
LACKEY MELENDEZ AND.
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY THREE ONE
VOTING WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ISSUE TWENTY
WHICH IS A SEXUAL ASSAULT KITS
APPROVED THE PROPOSAL AND ADAPT
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL.
WEBER I'VE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS ON A FOR A VOTE AND WE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THIS IS THE BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE THIS IS
APPROVED THE PROPOSAL ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
MELENDEZ NO STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY THREE ONE VOTE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ISSUE TWENTY TWO WHICH
IS E. CRIME UNIT IS WEBSITE
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL RECOMMEND.
THE ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE
STONE. THAT IS OUT ON A FOR ALL
VOTER WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ISSUE TWENTY
THREE THE JUVENILE COURT AND
PROBATION STATISTICAL SYSTEM
THIS IS APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
ROCO WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
IT IS OUT ONLY FOR ALL VOTE. OF
THIS IS ISSUE TWENTY FOUR SAN
JOAQUIN NEW STOCKTON COURTHOUSE
THEY PULLED THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER. A ROLL CALL.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FOR ALL VOTE.
AND WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ISSUE TWENTY FIVE
WHICH IS THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
MID COUNTY.
CIVIL COURTHOUSE THIS IS THE
PROOF THE SPRING FINANCE LETTER.
ROLL CALL. WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY MELENDEZ AYE
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FOR ALL VOTE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN. THIS IS THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH FUNDING ISSUE
TWENTY SIX THIS IS A PROOF FORTY
SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION TO
UNDERFUNDED COURTS AND APPROVED
THE SEVEN FIVE MILLION
DISCRETIONARY FUNDING. BROKEN
DOWN TO FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
COURT REPORTERS AND FAMILY COURT
PROCEEDINGS THIRTY MILLION TO
TRIAL COURTS AND THIRTY MILLIONS
TO DISCRETION PHONE TWO DISHES
COUNSEL AT. AN APPROVED BUDGET
BILL AND PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL. WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY
MELENDEZ AYE STONE. IS OUT ONLY
FOUR OH VOTE WITHOUT WILL HOLD
IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS THE SITE PRAY.
.
THE ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN THIS IS
ADOPT PLACEHOLDERS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REFLECTED IN THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ OF STATE.
STONE.
IS THE REST OF THREE ONE VOTE
AND.
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBER ONCE HE GETS.
IN. AND GETS HIS MATERIAL ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH IS THE
TRAFFIC TICKETS AND LICENSE
SUSPENSIONS THIS IS ADOPT
TRAILER BILL PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE REFLECTED IN THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION. ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT ROLL CALL. WEBER
AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY YES.
MELINDA'S.
STAYING
STONE.
OKAY THAT IS OUT ONLY FOR ONE
VOTE IN ONE ABSTENTION.
.
NO I'M SORRY THERE'S NO NO VOTE
YET THAT'S ONE EXTENSION SERVICE
THAT. A ISSUE TWENTY NINE SO
ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT WAS FOUR
VOTES.
A NO NO VOTES AND ONE ABSTENTION.
ISSUE TWENTY NINE THE JUDGESHIPS
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ROLL CALL WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY LIVE MELINDA'S AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A BIBLE VOTE.
.
JUDICIAL BRANCH.
CAPITAL LAY OUT OF ISSUE THIRTY
IS APPROVE THE PROPOSED FUNDING
AND ADOPT TRAILER BILL
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL AND
PLACEMENT PLACEHOLDER BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRE A
REASSESSMENT OF THE IMMEDIATE
CRITICAL IN HIGH NEED PROJECTS.
BEFORE THE FINAL SELECTION OF
PROJECTS.
A ISSUE THIRTY ROLL CALL WEBER
PIE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
OKAY THAT IS OUT ON FIVE OH.
ISSUE TO THIRTY ONE WHICH IS
EQUAL ACCESS FUN OF THIS IS TO
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
NOT VOTING.
MELENDEZ ABSTAINED.
STONE.
SO THERE IS ONLY THREE ZERO AND
TWO ABSTENTIONS.
ISSUE TWENTY THIRTY TWO WHICH IS
A COURT TRANSCRIPT FEES FOR
INDIGENT PEOPLE APPROVE THE
PROPOSAL BROKAW WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY. MELENDEZ AYE
STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE WILL VOTE.
A ISSUE TH THIRTY THREE THE
COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES THIS IS TO
ADOPT THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE. ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
AYE MELENDEZ AYE STONE. THAT IS
OUT ON A FIVE WILL VOTE. ISSUE
THIRTY FOUR WHICH IS THE INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE ACT THIS IS TO
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER. BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ROLL CALL WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY AYE
MELENDEZ AYE STONE. THAT IS OUT
ON A FIVE WILL VOTE. ISSUE
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS THE
STARBASE BASE YOUTH PROGRAM THE
APPROVED THE PROPOSAL ROLL CALL.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER. LACKEY AYE
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE.
ISSUE THIRTY SIX WHICH IS A
YOUTH REINVESTMENT FUND THEIR
PULL THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL AND A
PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
BROKAW WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
STRONG I.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE DRUG.
NO MORE MONEY WITH A STRONG WEEK
YOU KNOW.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE WILL VOTE
YOU THREE INVESTMENT FUND. ISSUE
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS CAL VIP
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
ROLL CALL.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY AYE MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT'S A FIVE OLD VOTE WITHOUT A
WOMAN KNOW THAT EACH THAT ITEMS
THIRTY EIGHT AND THIRTY NINE
THEY ARE REVERSED IN THE BODY OF
THE GENDER BUT WE WILL TAKE THEM
UP IN THE INDEX ORDER SERVE YOU
COULD INDEX. THE INDEX IS
CORRECT THE IN THE AGENDA OF THE
INFORMATION HAS BEEN REVERSED
SOLVE THE FIRST ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT IS THE REENTRY PROGRAMS
AND THIS APPROVED A PROPOSAL AND
ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT.
REENTRY PROGRAMS ROLL CALL WEBER
I'VE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY THEY MELINDA'S ABSTAINED.
STONE.
THAT'S A THREE ZERO ONE TWO
ABSTENTIONS AND THAT IS OUT.
A ISSUE THIRTY NINE WHICH IS A
CITY OF STOCKTON APPROVED A
PROPOSAL IN ADOPTING A SODA
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THERE IS OUT ONLY FOR FIVE WILL
VOTE.
ISSUE FORTY WHICH IS THE LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENTS THEY PULL THE
PROPOSAL THAT BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ROLL CALL WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY FIVE MELINDA AND I STONE.
THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE.
.
ISSUE FORTY ONE BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUB TO PULL THE PROPOSAL AND A
PLACE HOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ROLL CALL WEBER. AYE
JONES SAWYER LACKEY. MELENDEZ
AYE
STONE.
IT IS OUT ON A FIVE OH VOTE.
ISSUE FORTY TWO WHICH IS TO
PROMOTE OATH APPROVE THE
PROPOSED AND ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY.
STATE MELENDEZ SUBSTANCE STONE.
THERE'S ONLY THREE WOULD ZERO NO
VOTES AND TWO ABSTENTIONS.
ISSUE FORTY THREE WHICH IS THE
VETERANS TRANSITION CENTER THE
PULL THE PROPOSAL ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
A ROLL CALL. WEBER AYE JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
OKAY THAT IS OUT ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE. ISSUE FORTY FOUR WHICH IS
A QUORUM IS FEE REVENUE SHIFT TO
THE STATE PENALTY FUND ADOPT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ROCO.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER. LACKEY
AYE MELENDEZ AYE STONE. THAT IS
OUT ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE ENCANTO
RECREATIONAL CENTER PULL THE
PROPOSAL ADOPT PLACEHOLDER
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY. MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE
A LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT
PLACEHOLDER BUDGET BILL AND PLAY
SOLO TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ROLL
CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY AYE MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THERE'S OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE
OF THE MODEL HATE CRIME POLICY
TO PULL THE PROPOSAL AND ADOPT
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE. I'LL ROLL
CALL. WEBER I'VE JONES SAWYER
LACKEY. MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
THAT IS OUT ONLY FIVE ZERO VOTE
WE ABOVE COMPLETED OUR VOTING
WILL GO BACK TO DO THOUGH THOSE
WHO WERE NOT HERE TO TAKE THOSE
VOTES FROM THE BEGINNING. BUT OF
BECAUSE THE OTHER MEMBERS MAY BE
LEAVING I JUST SIMPLY WANT
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO THE
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
WHO BASICALLY ATTENDED THE
MEETINGS AND PARTICIPATE IN A
CONVERSATION CHALLENGE THIS ALL
DID AN EXCELLENT JOB AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK? THOSE OF YOU WHO
BE SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE.
WE MAY MEET AGAIN.
HOPE NOT BUT WE MAY MEET AGAIN.
ABOUT SOME OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND THINGS IT'S HERE IN
ISSUES AND SO YOU MAY HEAR SOME
ADDITIONAL THINGS I REALLY WANT
TO THANK. EVERYONE WHO SERVICE
COMMITTEE IT'S AN EXTRA DUTY IN
X. RESPONSIBLE SERVE ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND A THAT IT.
BRINGS YOU TO A WHOLE NOTHER
LEVEL OF APPRECIATION OF
DIALOGUE IN CONVERSATION BUT I
REALLY WANT THANK THOSE MEMBERS
WHO HAVE PARTICIPATED ON THIS
COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP. IN THIS AREA FROM
THE VARIOUS HOUSES THAT WE COME
FROM PLACES BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
BEFORE WE ADJOURN WE WILL GO
BACK OVER THE BILLS THAT HAD
THAT THOSE IF YOU WERE HERE FOR
THE BEGINNING YOU CAN. EITHER
STAND WITNESS SAID ARE YOU IF
YOU.
I HAVE NOTHING ELSE IN LIFE TO
DO BUT OTHER THAN THAT YOU CAN
STAND WILL START AT THE TOP WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ISSUE ONE THE VOTE WAS THREE TO
ZERO ROLL CALL FOR THOSE ABSENT
MEMBERS LACKEY ON. JONES SAWYER
BY.
THAT THAT VOTE NOW IS FIVE ZERO
OKAY JANITORIAL SERVICES AT
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. OF THAT VOTE
CURRENTLY IS THREE ZERO ROLL
CALL JONES SAWYER. LACKEY.
THAT BRINGS US TO A FIVE ZERO
VOTE. OF.
TO READ GOV ISSUE THREE THE
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ACADEMY THAT VOTES KILEY THREE
ZERO ROLL CALL JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY THAT'S FIVE ZERO OKAY OF
VEHICLE PURCHASING AUTHORITY FOR
THE PRISON INDUSTRIAL FORTY.
.
THAT VOTE CURRENTLY IS THREE
ZERO ROLL CALL JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY ON THAT IS FIVE ZERO IT'S
OUT. OF WE ARE DEALING WITH ONE
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON CALL THIS
ISSUE FIVE. THAT'S A FACILITY
MANAGEMENT AND CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSAL THE CURRENT VOTERS TO
IN FAVOR NO NO VOTES AND ONE
ABSTENTION ROLL CALL JONES
SAWYER. LACKEY STATE.
THE BILL IS OUT ONLY THREE TWO
ZERO AND TWO EXTENSION.
OF AB NINE HUNDRED WHICH IS THE
LEAST OF REVENUE APPROPRIATION
AUTHORITY OF THAT VOTE CURRENT
IS THREE ZERO PROCOL. JONES
SAWYER LACKEY I'VE THAT'S A FIVE
ZERO VOTE. UP PELICAN BAY STATE
PRISON A FACILITY DE YARD THE
VOTE IS CURRENTLY THREE.
WITH THOUGH ONE NO VOTE AND.
ROLL CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS LACKEY.
NO.
OKAY SO THAT'S THREE DUE TO ITS
OUT.
OF ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
CALIFORNIA EARLY EARTHQUAKE
WARNING SYSTEM AS IT CURRENTLY
PASSED OUT OF WOOD FOUR ZERO
VOTE ROLL CALL. LACKEY AYE.
THE FIVE ZERO OKAY AND THEN A
NINE ONE ONE SUSTAINMENT IS.
IT CURRENTLY AT A FOUR ZERO
VOTE ISSUE NUMBER NINE ROLL CALL.
LACKEY I'VE THAT'S A FIVE ZERO
VOTE THAT'S OUT IN FIVE ZERO.
ISSUE NUMBER TEN A WHICH IS THE
DESK DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATION ACCOUNT IT'S CURRENTLY
AT FOUR ZERO ROLL CALL LACKEY.
OKAY THAT'S A FIVE ZERO OUT.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT SERVICES IS CURRENTLY AT
A FOUR ZERO OF VOTE ROLL CALL
LACKEY.
IT'S FIVE ZERO OKAY A SERVICES
FOR VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
ROLL CALL THAT'S IT CURRENT IF
FOUR ZERO LACKEY AYE.
IF THAT IS FIVE ZERO IT'S OUT OF
THE INTERNET CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN.
IS AT FOUR ZERO ROLL CALL
LACKEY.
THE KID THAT IS CURRENTLY A FIVE
TO ZERO THAT'S OUT. OF THE
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTERS THAT IS
CURRENTLY FOUR ZERO VOTE OF.
ROLL CALL LACKEY.
OKAY FIVE ZERO THAT IS OUT OF
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER IT IS
CURRENTLY A FOUR ZERO VOTE ROLL
CALL. LACKEY.
THAT'S OKAY THIS ISSUE FIFTEEN
OF FIVE ZERO. OTHER CITY OF
RIALTO IS AT A FOUR ZERO. VOTES
SO ROLL CALL.
LACKEY I OKAY THAT IS FIVE ZERO
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT SIXTEEN.
ISSUE SEVENTEEN WHICH IS A
CYBERSECURITY INVESTMENT
INVESTIGATION TEAM IS CURRENTLY
AT A FLORIDA ZERO VOTE ROLL CALL.
LACKEY ARE.
OKAY THAT IS CURRENTLY FIVE ZERO.
ISSUE EIGHTEEN IS THE ARMED AND
PROFIT WILL PROHIBIT A PERSON
SYSTEM ROLL CALL US AT FOUR ZERO
RIGHT NOW LACKEY AYE. IT'S
CURRENTLY OUT AT FIVE ZERO.
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN WHICH IS
STATE OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING
INVESTIGATION TEAM THIS AT A
THREE TO ONE VOTE ROLL CALL
LACKEY.
THAT MAKES IT FOUR ONE OKAY AND
THAT BILL IS OUT SEXUAL ASSAULT
KITS IS CURRENTLY A FOUR ZERO
OUT OF ITS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
ROLL CALL. LACKEY AYE.
IT'S FIVE ZERO. OF THE BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE APPROVED
OF. A RECOMMENDATION THAT'S A
THREE TO ONE VOTE ROLL CALL.
LACKEY NO.
OKAY SO THAT'S THREE TO TWO IT'S
OUT WITH THREE TO TWO A E. CRIME.
UNIT WEBSITE.
ISSUE TWENTY TWO ROLL CALL
LACKEY. OVER THAT'S AT A FIVE
ZERO VOTE. AND.
PUT AYE ISSUE TWENTY THREE THE
JUVENILE COURT AMPLE BASINS US
INTO SCHOOL SYSTEM SCARLET
AFFORD ZERO VOTE ROLL CALL
LACKEY.
IT'S NOT FIVE ZERO. A ISSUE
TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS SAN JOAQUIN
NEW STOCKTON COURTHOUSE.
IT'S AT A FOUR ZERO VOTE ROLL
CALL. LACKEY. THAT'S FIVE ZERO.
OKAY RIVERSIDE COUNTY NEW MID
COUNTY CIVIL A COURTHOUSE IT'S
CURRENTLY FORTY. VOTE LOCAL.
LACKEY I'VE
OKAY THAT'S OUT ON A FIVE ZERO
ISSUED TWENTY FIVE ISSUE TWENTY
SIX THE JUDICIAL BRANCH FUNDING
IS AT FOUR ZERO ROLL CALL LACKEY.
THAT'S AT FIVE TWO ZERO.
AND.
PLACEHOLDER TRADE ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN SI PREY.
ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN WILL CAUSE
KILEY A THREE TO ONE.
OH I'M SORRY THREE EYES AND ONE
NOT VOTING OKAY SO THERE'S NO NO
VOTES ON THAT ONE OF ROLL CALL
LACKEY.
OKAY SO WE HAVE THREE VOTES AND
TWO ABSTENTIONS THAT BILL IS OUT
TO SIGH PRAY OF.
AND I THINK THAT COVERS THEM ALL.
IS THAT RIGHT.
IT'S IT WITH YOU THANK YOU THE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
SO I'M AT MY GOAL